It's a very rapidly changing field.
That's where the landscape
changes constantly,
the technologies change constantly.
How does one become a successful
cyber security professional?
>From your perspective, I guess,
I'm sure you have heard about what
it means to be a successful cyber
security professional on your side?
>> Well I think to be successful,
I mean, you can't stand still.
To stand still is to get left behind.
So you have to have a passion for
the discipline.
And to really be a constant learner and
being able to think creatively and
consume and learn and create new things
and also be interested in how to take
things apart and push technologies
in ways that they weren't intended.
I also think though to be successful,
you have to be trustworthy.
Because by studying
information security,
you're learning effectively dangerous
skills that you have to use wisely.
People will put their trust into you and
you have to respect that.
That's really a key, probably the key
underpinning the whole discipline.
A willingness to teach others about
this in a way that's the right language.
Taking a step back,
I'd say you have to be able to
communicate technical subjects
to non-technical audiences in a way
that's understandable and meaningful.
How you communicate with
potentially board of directors,
there's a whole lexicon of how you
communicate with senior business leaders
or senior military leaders, or students.
It varies, so you have to be very
adaptive and be willing to learn and
respect the cultures which you're trying
to interact with in a positive way.